bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous nouvelles règles donc aujourd'hui
on vient d'en parler mais invitation
tout de même à l'otan confinement y
compris les enfants qu'ils n'iraient pas
l'école en tout cas ce serait mieux nous
at-on fait comprendre sans obligation
n'est ce pas les français peuvent-ils y
voir clair selon vous vous avez dit
comprendre je crois que le problème
c'est là qu'est ce qu'on comprend de ces
mesures finalement qui sont
incompréhensibles
puisque il y a quelques mois jean michel
blanquer faisait que les écoles n'était
pas le lieu de contamination que les
enfants n'étaient pas porteurs
finalement il n'était pas plus
contaminantes les autres voire moins et
puis là on nous dit que ce serait bien
que les enfants rate l'école un deux
jours avant la fin de la semaine pour
être sûrs qu'ils n'emmènent pas le coc
vide dans les familles mais les
professeurs eux en revanche devrait
aller à l'école puisque jean-michel
bancaire se félicite qu'il n'y ait pas
plus de cas de co vite dans les écoles
auriez eu beaucoup de quatre communes
malheureusement au sein des classes mais
aussi au sein du personnel enseignant et
tout ça dans une dans une impréparation
comme d'habitude finalement puisque
c'est lundi soir très tard que la
nouvelle a été annoncée que l'oeil
l'école n'était plus obligatoire cette
semaine parce qu'ils avaient une commune
et donc les enfants n'étaient pas
obligés d'y aller pour deux jours mais
quelle est la logique finalement avec
tout ce qu'on me l'a dit pendant des
mois
si on cherche la logique dans les
mesures de confinement de déconfinement
de stop and go comme ça a été dit dans
le reportage bien on ne trouvera pas de
choses évidentes on a l'impression
d'improvisation permanente difficile et
angoissante pour les français alors ça
suscite évidemment de la colère colère
notamment du monde de la culture on l'a
vu aujourd'hui et des restaurateurs qui
ne sont plus sûrs de rouvrir le 20
janvier à leur grand désespoir
on sent que la grogne nom de plus en
plus dans le pays
oui la grogne monte de plus en plus et
c'est compréhensible
le secteur de la culture extrêmement
touché par ces confinement à répétition
qui ne comprend pas les mesures qui sont
prises puisque encore une fois les
salles de cinéma la salle du théâtre
n'était pas des lieux de contamination
n'était pas des clusters comme on dit
donc pourquoi alors que tout le monde
avait respecté les consignes on décide
de fermer sans avoir de date de
réouverture extrêmement claires les
restaurants qui sont les sacrifiés de
cette politique sanitaire et dont on dit
maintenant que finalement la date de
janvier ne seraient pas forcément sur
est assurée comment voulez vous préparer
un plan une année un budget quand vous
êtes soumis au bon vouloir d'un conseil
de sécurité d'un conseil de défense qui
va décider d'un mois sur l'autre que
vous avez le droit d'ouvrir quinze jours
ou pas et qu' on ne sera pas comment
tout ça va se passer
les aides elles sont là elles sont
présentes les minimisons pas mais elle
ne touche pas tout le monde
il ya des gens qui ont ouvert des
commerces des sociétés trop tard pour en
bénéficier
et puis elles ne seront pas suffisantes
l'autorité bancaire européenne vient
d'alerter les banques françaises et
européennes de faillite nombreuses qui
vont arriver en 2021 et d'un risque
systémique de faillite des banques
puisque derrière ces des dettes qui ne
vont pas être payé et on parle de 1700
milliards de dettes privées
d'entreprises et d'être privés et là il
n'y a pas de plan on fait de l'argent
magique avec la bce ont fait des aides
de la manière improvisée comme
d'habitude pour le secteur culturel et
autres
mais ce n'est pas suffisant pour sauver
le nombre d'emplois des intermittents le
nombre d'emplois aussi dans la
restauration les emplois aussi étudiants
qui sont nécessaires pour les étudiants
qui sont je le rappelle les jeunes sont
les plus touchés de ses mesures
sanitaires de l'ue de contrôler qu'ovide
et il se retrouve à faire la queue aux
banques alimentaires ils se retrouvent
privés de revenus par ces petits boulots
qu'il faisait avant et qui est leur
permettait de subvenir à leurs besoins
aujourd'hui on est en train de sacrifier
les plus jeunes on est en train de
sacrifier des secteurs entiers sous
prétexte de lutter contre un virus dont
le taux de mortalité je le rappelle
n'est quand même pas catastrophique il
touche les plus âgés ils touchent
certaines pathologies des jeunes aussi
il est dangereux virus il existe mais
pourquoi autant d'acharnement autant de
difficultés autant de bâtons dans les
roues pour des secteurs économiques qui
ne demande qu'à accueillir du monde etc
à travailler dans ce contexte très tendu
on se demande quelles pourraient être
les conséquences sur une éventuelle
j'aime candidature d'emmanuel maquereau
en 2022 même si c'est loin c'est demain
matin finalement pour en parler alexis
avant de faire réagir je vous propose
d'écouter le chef de l'état un excès
intéressant sur lors de son interview
sur le magazine d'information site
d'informations brutes écouter peut-être
que je pourrai pas être candidat
peut-être que je devrais faire des
choses dans la dernière année dans les
derniers mois
dur parce que les circonstances
l'exigeront et qui rendront impossible
le fait que je sois candidat je n'exclus
rien on a vécu des choses qui étaient
absolument imprévisible alors justement
la stratégie du coc vie des restrictions
que nous impose le gouvernement est ce
que ça pourrait faire partie selon vous
de ces choses dures auquel a fait
référence
emmanuel macron oui ça pourrait tout à
fait en faire partie c'est des mots qui
sont extrêmement inquiétant parce que ça
voudrait dire qu emmanuel macron est en
train de faire des scénarios sur ce que
seraient les mois à venir
on a vu un plusieurs scénarios sur
déconfinement re confinement avec sans
vaccins avec ou pas deuxième vague avec
une recombinase ation de ce virus
le problème c'est que qu'est ce que ça
veut dire des choses dures on a vu des
choses dures de ce gouvernement la façon
dont ont été traités les manifestants
lors des actes des dirigeants le
week-end dernier le nombre
d'arrestations abusives qui ont été
constatés par les associations des
droits de l'homme mais aussi simplement
par la justice qui a libéré les gens
arrêtés qui n'étaient pas des black
blocs qui n'étaient pas des séditieux
qui n'étaient pas des gens qui étaient
là pour mettre en danger la république
mais simplement arrêter parce qu'ils
étaient là en train de manifester
donc une attaque manifeste au droit de
manifester ça c'est dangereux
inquiétant ces mots là finalement ils
sont des mots à tiroirs qu'est ce que
c'est que des choses dures est-ce que
c'est davantage encore de lois
liberticides comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui des lois de censure sur les
réseaux sociaux des lois de censure
aussi sur la liberté d'expression la
liberté de l'express tout ça qui a été
montré du doigt par les instances
internationales
est-ce que c'est davantage de mesures
sanitaires qui vont être là aussi
liberticide
quoi qu'il en soit des mots dans la
bouche d'un président en disant qu'il va
être obligé de faire des choses dures
potentiellement l'année où il serait
capable de se représenter
ne disent qu'une chose c'est que
emmanuel macron est prêt à aller
jusqu'au bout
or quand il a été élu en 2017 il a été
élu comme le réformateur ce président
qui devait faire des réformes
systémiques changer la france
la moderniser c'était son discours
depuis 2010 est son bilan est
extrêmement maigre et c'était bien avant
le coc vide
il n'a fait que très peu de réformes et
la grande réforme celle des retraites
elle est à l'arrêt clairement elle
n'arrivera pas avant 2022
richard ferrand parle même d'un deuxième
quinquennat sur le ton de la blague
peut-être mais en disant qu'il faudrait
un deuxième quinquennat pour faire la
réforme des retraites parce que pour ce
premier quinquennat
les réformes sont à l'arrêt et même les
réformes avant coville n'ont pas eu lieu
donc emmanuel macron a vendu a survendu
c'était cette image de la start up née
schott du président jeunes du maine
nouveau et on se rend compte qu'il
continue une politique à la françois
hollande où rien ne se passe ou
finalement et bien il fait semblant mais
il ne se passe rien si ce n'est de la
répression davantage de lois
liberticides et moins de liberté
d'expression c'est inquiétant je crois
qu'il faut que nous soyons conscients
des dangers qui sont devant nous et que
ce virus ne peut pas tout excuser
loin de là et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui dans la rue que vous
aviez à la fois le monde du spectacle
monde de la restauration et les gens qui
luttent pour défendre nos libertés qui
sont présents et qui sont présents
encore tous les week-ends le risque
c'est en 2021
beaucoup de faillites est davantage de
monde dans la rue parce que aujourd'hui
les instances représentatives que sont
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat sont
faibles et que les contre-pouvoirs sont
faibles et donc les français préfèrent
être dans la rue pour faire valoir leurs
droits c'est grave et j'espère qu'en
2022 mails mac on pourra se présenter et
qu'il n'aura pas à prendre des décisions
ou dur
merci alexis poulain pour cet édito
vértiable